Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson has promised "the
hierarchy of power is about to change" in the
DCEU. But who exactly is Black Adam,
and how does he fit into the series'
timeline? Here's everything we know about
this anti-hero's history – and his future.
Warning, spoilers ahead.
"Here we go."
Possibly the oldest DCEU character
to date, Black Adam was born five
thousand years ago, likely predating even
Wonder Woman's birth. Teth-Adam began as a
slave of the fictional country Kahndaq where
he lost his son, who died saving his father.
In the comics, the wizard Shazam grants Teth-Adam
the powers of gods, not knowing that the former
slave holds no restraint in delivering deadly
justice to his abusers. In Black Adam's original
comic book origin from Fawcett Comics, which takes
place before the character was acquired by DC,
he destroys the Pharaoh and Kahndaq's elite
before claiming the throne for himself.
After Black Adam's rampage in Kahndaq,
the wizard realizes his mistake in
bestowing Teth-Adam with the powers
of gods. Unable to remove his powers,
Shazam renames the violent being "Black Adam"
and banishes him from the world of mankind.
In the original Fawcett origin, the wizard
teleports Black Adam to the other side of
the universe, forcing the villain to spend the
next 5,000 years flying back to Earth. However,
the film's teaser shows the wizard Shazam
using his magic to seemingly entomb Black
Adam for thousands of years, giving him time
to find a new champion. In the modern day,
humans free the demigod, who
awakens in a strange new world.
By the time Black Adam escapes his
tomb, the citizens of the DCEU have
already experienced plenty of
bizarre and dangerous threats.
Aliens from Krypton tried to destroy the world.
A beast known as Doomsday nearly destroyed
Metropolis and killed Superman. Atlantean armies
fought over whether or not to destroy life on
the surface world. The Enchantress nearly
toppled Midway City. A giant starfish named
Starro visited terror upon Corto Maltese. And
alien butterflies threatened to take over the
world. Thankfully, humanity lives in an era
of superheroes who can combat such threats.
HBO Max's "Peacemaker" series offers a
clue as to when Black Adam emerges into
this age of heroes. In the fourth episode the
anti-hero Vigilante gets himself arrested to
get thrown into prison and kill Peacemaker's
father. In a courtyard where security guards
are having lunch, one guard is seen reading
a newspaper with an article indicating an
organization known as "Intergang'' has
seized power in the nation of Kahndaq.
In DC Comics, Intergang is a criminal
organization that uses advanced weaponry
obtained from the alien planet Apokolips
to further their agenda. Since Black Adam
considers himself the protector of Kahndaq, once
he returns, he'll definitely want to have a few
words with Intergang. This suggests "Black
Adam" will occur sometime after "Peacemaker."
In comic book lore, there have
been several versions of Black
Adam and his origins. In "Shazam! Vol. 1,"
written by DC comics maestro Geoff Johns,
we learn Black Adam is imprisoned by the wizard in
a tomb for his evil deeds, much like in the movie.
While researching the villain, Shazam's current
champion Billy Batson gets a glimpse into the
past and witnesses a boy named Aman trying to
survive oppression along with his uncle. The
boy is given powers by the wizard Shazam,
and Billy incorrectly assumes Aman becomes
Black Adam. However, he later learns
Aman's uncle steals his nephew's power,
kills The Wizard's intended champion,
and transforms into Black Adam.
In the modern age, Dr. Sivana uncovers the
entrance to Black Adam's prison. He says
the magic word, "Shazam!" and frees Black Adam,
who goes in search of Billy Batson in an attempt
to defeat him and become the ultimate champion.
The new DCEU film makes changes to
the comic book origin, focusing on
Teth-Adam's relationship with his son,
not his nephew. The movie also doesn't
feature Shazam or his young counterpart Billy
Batson. However, Black Adam does get released
from his magical prison to bring his brand of
justice down on those he deems deserving of
his rage. This puts him in conflict with many
of Earth's heroes, including some new faces.
Black Adam's primary antagonists will be the
Justice Society of America. The JSA is a group
of heroes who came together during DC's Golden Age
of comics in the 1940s. In many DC continuities,
the JSA predates the Justice League and
clashed with the enemies of its era,
including the tyrannical Nazi regime. While
JSA members have all appeared in modern comics,
the JSA is typically recognized as a superhero
team from a classic era with much older heroes.
"The only thing we can learn from these
geezers is how to add more fiber to our diets!"
The JSA includes famous members such
as the original Flash, Jay Garrick,
as well as the first human Green Lantern,
Alan Scott. However, "Black Adam" will focus
on other JSA members including Hawkman,
Dr. Fate, Atom Smasher, and Cyclone.
How these heroes came to be in the DCEU is
unknown. Unlike Superman or Wonder Woman,
we haven't received an origin tale for any of
these heroes. However, if they're anything like
their comic book counterparts, Dr. Fate and
Hawkman are both born from ancient powers. Dr.
Fate is a creation of a cosmic deity while
Hawkman was the Egyptian prince Khufu who,
after being killed with a mystical
dagger, is bound to be reincarnated
upon death. During the JSA era, Hawkman
is reborn as Carter Hall who adopts the
mantle of Hawkman using alien antigravity
Nth metal to power his armor and weaponry.
As for Atom Smasher, he's the heroic grandson of
the supervillain Cyclotron in the comics, gifted
with super strength and the ability to control
the size and density of his body. Meanwhile,
Cyclone is the granddaughter of the original
Red Tornado and possesses the powers of flight,
wind control, and sound wave control. Both
are legacy heroes with strong ties to the JSA.
"Black Adam" occurs primarily in the
modern day after the events of the
theatrical-released "Justice League." This
means the JSA and Justice League co-exist in
the same era. However, this doesn't explain
why the JSA are the only heroes who seem
to be responding to the climactic events
after Black Adam emerges from his prison.
While the Justice League took
some time to come together,
its individual members have been active for
years. Kal-El revealed himself years ago as
Superman while Black Adam was still stuck
in limbo. Wonder Woman made herself known
to humanity during the First World War. Bruce
Wayne has been operating as Batman for decades.
And both Aquaman and the Flash had superhero
careers long before joining the Justice League.
The greater DCEU is familiar with these rock
stars, but the JSA still seems relatively
unknown. It'll be interesting to see how
the timelines link up and learn what the
Justice League is doing when Black
Adam makes himself known. Notably,
Amanda Waller from DCEU's "Suicide Squad"
films is working with the JSA and has
some pull with certain League members,
including a certain famous Kryptonian.
Empowered by the gods themselves, Black
Adam is an insanely powerful being,
and what better way to show this by having
him challenge the alpha of DC superheroes,
Superman? In DC Comics, Black Adam has always
been a formidable foe for powerhouses like
Superman and Shazam. Notably, aside from
Kryptonite, Superman is vulnerable to magic,
something Black Adam can produce punishing
amounts of thanks to his divine gifts.
After a Twitter fan expressed a desire to see
these two titans come together. Johnson retweeted
the message and shared that he always aims to
listen to his audience. "I hear you & I always got
you," stated the Rock. In the film's mid credit
scene, we see Johnson make good on his promise.
After being informed by Amanda Waller
that he is not to leave Khandaq's borders,
Black Adam arrogantly informs her that no one can
stop him from doing what he wants. In response,
Waller sends Superman to confront Black Adam,
who informs the demigod that they should talk.
No word on whether or not this will lead to a
big screen battle between the two, but with Henry
Cavill back in the Superman suit, we'll likely
be seeing more of both the hero and anti-hero.
Shazam and Black Adam are like the Joker and
Batman. Young Billy Batson as the all-powerful
hero Shazam seeks to do good and uphold a
heroic standard. Black Adam doesn't live by
a code of any kind. His goal is singular
in his mind, and no act is too amoral or
dicey if it furthers his objective of
obliterating tyranny and opposition.
Yet despite these moral differences,
Shazam and Black Adam are ultimately two
sides of the same coin, imbued with godly
powers by the same wizard. In the comics,
the wizard saw the error of his ways and
banished Black Adam until a hero could
be called forward to defeat him. With the rise
of Billy Batson as Shazam, that time had come.
However, this is a film focused on the "bad
guy" — a move meant to position Black Adam as
a sympathetic anti-hero. Shazam is nowhere to
be seen, and director Jaume Collet-Serra said
not to expect a Shazam-Black Adam match-up just
yet. In an interview with "Variety," he stated:
"Our movie is an original story.
By the time the movie ends,
he doesn't know who Shazam or Superman is."
However, it's fairly certain that "Black Adam"
takes place after the first "Shazam!" film.
If Black Adam were around during the events of
"Shazam!" he would have most certainly confronted
Billy over his powers. Black Adam doesn't want
a champion standing in the way of his goals,
and wants to be a supreme power. Eliminating
Shazam is the only means to that end. The two will
inevitably meet in the DCEU, however, even if it
isn't in Black Adam's first outing. It's destiny.
While Shazam won't appear in "Black Adam,"
audiences will be seeing Billy Batson's
superpowered alter ego very soon. "Shazam: Fury
of the Gods'' is set to release in March 2023.
Instead of Black Adam, however, the sequel
will feature a wildly new antagonist in the
form of Helen Mirren's Hespera, a jealous
god seeking the power of Shazam for herself.
With Black Adam busy contending with
Intergang in Kahndaq and Shazam working
with his family to dispel evil on the
other side of the world in Philly,
it's unlikely that these two will come to
blows. It also remains to be seen if either
film will tease a future clash or if either
character cameos in the opposite film. From
a timeline perspective, however, consider
these films either happening concurrently
or relatively close together, allowing the
two champions to remain separate… for now.
With the future of the Justice League up in
the air, there may be a brand-new world for
Black Adam to conquer in the DCEU. Ben Affleck is
wrapping up his time as Batman with the upcoming
"The Flash" movie. It's hard to believe Ray
Fisher will be back as Cyborg any time soon
after his feud with Warner Bros. And the
Flash, as portrayed by Ezra Miller, will
almost definitely not return outside of his solo
project, after the actor's various alleged crimes.
Meanwhile, Wonder Woman is primed for a third
film, rounding out a trilogy for the Amazonian
warrior. "Aquaman and the Lost Kingdom"
is also in the works, while Henry Cavill's
involvement as Superman in future DCEU movies
has been confirmed with that post credit scene.
With Black Adam about to make his mark in the
DCEU, could Johnson's take on the Man in Black
be the one that leads us into the future of DCEU?
The remaining heroes — Aquaman, Wonder Woman,
Shazam, and whoever from the JSA survives
"Black Adam" — could use a central hero or
a unifying villain. The film universe is on the
precipice of a shake-up as Warner Bros. seems
bent on abandoning what Zack Snyder began. With
a leading man like Johnson, anything is possible.